we ain't got a lot of it but respect
what we have uh
surely tom brady had something to do
with it surely he's been banging the
drum for antonio brown and the fact that
there's been so many receiver injuries
plays right into it hey i don't have
healthy receivers get me
get me antonio brown get me antonio
brown he probably said it enough times
where they finally said all right tom
we'll get you antonio brown well yeah
i mean you and it you know to what bruce
arians first said there it is an
insurance policy of course it is
they're a super bowl team they can win
the super bowl this year
if mike evans isn't healthy or out there
on a given week
that it's a big chunk of their chance
taken away
so to have that element is big let alone
if all of them are healthy and you got
gronk and you know antonio brown and
godwin and mike
evans on the field them i mean you
better be a special team
to play with them so that's where you
know it's great that way
across the board and i mean mike do you
hear what you're saying of course
i mean it's it's insane i mean i guess
bruce arians is trying to protect brady
maybe a little
to make it sound like he's not banging
on the drum for him too hard
because he doesn't want to disrespect
maybe some of the other wide receivers
in the locker room already and maybe you
know of course the old nfl way
everything's you know old school and in
that way where maybe they don't want it
to seem like they're taking orders from
any player that way
but he is in tampa bay because of tom
freak and brady
brady's brady's great he's a great
teammate
he's got a great way with people and he
obviously bonded with antonio brown and
jason light being from
you know being from new england already
and having a relationship with brady and
not being afraid to take a chance on
some guys like antonio brown
that's why he's there i don't think
bruce wanted him i just think
tom massaged it and finally got what he
wanted
and it's one thing to say it's an
insurance policy but here's the thing
once antonio brown is there do you think
he's going to be
comfortable in a given week let's say oh
all their guys are healthy we don't need
antonio brown he'll be inactive this
weekend or
or or we're not going to put him on the
field or we're not going to throw in the
football we don't need them we've got
chris goblin healthy we've got mike
evans healthy we've got scottie miller
everything's fine we don't need you
he's not he's not going to be content to
be an insurance policy and tom brady's
not going to be content
to use him as an insurance policy look
whatever happened between those two guys
during the brief period of time they
were together in new england it has
built a bond
that has lasted it has endured and tom
brady feels responsible
for antonio brown he feels like he can
speak to his better angels
and get the best out of him right and
he's going to want him on the field
and he's going to want to throw him the
football even when he's not the primary
read or even if he's not
open he's going to trust him again
whatever it was
it clicked and it worked and it only
works if antonio
brown's on the field catching the
football and and if antonio brown's not
being used
does he act up and if he acts up is he
truly on a one strike well
if he acts up he's done forever in the
nfl no
but but wait but here's the thing deep
trump bruce aaron's told jay glazer
yesterday that
he's going to tell antonio brown be a
team player or be gone
yeah but but still before they
cut him aren't they going to give
tom a chance to talk them out of it i i
that they they're i just can't imagine
now that he's there if it gets to that
conversation though then that means he
has to be cut
you know that that's just really it is
and hopefully tom can realize that at
that point
if they're having that conversation in
four weeks from now going
we might then he needs to be cut that
means there's already an issue
so this is antonio brown's last strike
in a lot of ways i mean
maybe he gets another one i don't know
but it's certainly
with his history and now his
relationship with brady
and if that somehow didn't work here
with a coach who's willing to take on
personalities
i mean i i would have a hard time
thinking antonio brown gets back in
football to where
he's gonna have to be on his best
behavior and i don't think
they are gonna use him like you know the
bad way in which you're saying he's
i think he'll be a part of the offense
he will we'll see how good he is i think
that's gonna dictate it a lot too
you know if if it's noticeably like
everyone's out there and they go well
he's just not as good as mike evans and
chris godwin
you know antonio brown might be able to
go okay i get it you know we're three
receivers in the game i'm in if there's
two receivers i'm not in
you know if if he is that good all right
i think they'll just find ways to infuse
them in the offense more
or they're going to be playing with fire
to like what you're saying
what do you think they say to the
receivers currently on the team who may
be thinking why the hell are we bringing
this guy here we're fine right
i i i don't know what they say to him i
think they just say
we're really damn good and
we need this aspect of our team to keep
our offense really dangerous and kind of
unstoppable
and we just need it for that insurance
policy aspect i think that's kind of
what they sell
to some of those guys the scotty millers
and everything like that
keep this in mind there's still a
pending civil lawsuit against antonio
brown alleging sexual assault and rape
it is set for trial
in december of this year the nfl
confirmed to me yesterday
brown is not out of the woods he could
still be disciplined for that
i think what happened was the nfl did
its investigation
the nfl decided we don't have enough
to make a decision let's see what
happens with this civil lawsuit
they'll have eventually if it goes to
trial they'll have testimony in open
court they'll have a verdict from a jury
and i think the nfl wants to reserve the
right to take action
depending upon how ugly this process
is and antonio brown hasn't even given
his pre-trial deposition yet
in that case and to be this close to
trial and to not have antonio brown
questioned under oath that in and of
itself will be a transcript of questions
and answers that the nfl can look at and
scrutinize
and we know from recent experience he
had a lawsuit that was filed against him
by a landlord
luxury apartment he blew a gasket
because somebody robbed him or something
he was throwing furniture out the window
all sorts of damage done he lost that
case in the default judgment because he
was grossly uncooperative with the
process
right and and and i'm i'm getting the
sense
that that same thing happening what
happened here
so look bruce erin said yesterday if it
turns out
he he's found to have done what he is
accused of doing he'll be gone
the league will take action that there's
a lot here that can still go on
before antonio brown uh ever makes the
kind of impact on a field that he did in
the past and i asked cam jordan
yesterday
the saints defensive end who will see
antonio brown week nine
sunday night football and antonio
brown's last great game
was against the saints late in the 2018
season he was phenomenal that day
steelers saints game in the superdome um
i i said
i said you know what do you think about
facing brown week nine and cam jordan
said he's got to get to week nine
and you know what it's some shade but
it's accurate
we don't know what's gonna happen with
this guy we don't know he's gonna be on
the team
in week nine and uh you know i'd say
there's a not
zero percent chance that he won't be on
the team in week nine chris
well i i mean that would be some turn of
events it really would be
i expect them to be there uh i do i know
there's
there's a lot to be you know told here
whatever we'll see how this all unfolds
but
nonetheless it's the buccaneers who
truly have gotten better just about
every
week all year and now they got another
weapon at brady's disposal an
offense that's really got just about
everything and
just watch out tampa bay here they come
baby
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports